eating this matzo ball soup makes me
feel warm and fuzzy inside it's the
perfect food for a cold day hi I'm Mike
today I'll show you how to make matzo
ball soup matzo ball soup is made from
matzo meal which is used to make the
unleavened flatbread that we eat for
Passover the Torah explains that because
the Jews left Egypt quickly there wasn't
time for their bread to rise and
therefore matzah serves as a reminder of
their escape this recipe is special to
me because it came from my grandparents
my grandparents were very proud of the
fact that their matzo balls were light
and fluffy
rather than dense there's a bit of
controversy surrounding whether or not
it's okay to use baking powder in matzo
balls for my grandparents it was the
secret ingredient for keeping the balls
light and fluffy some people feel like
it doesn't match the spirit of Passover
because it's technically a leavening
agent however its mineral based not
grain based and so it's not considered
part of the food group known as comets
it's prohibited on Passover they're also
a bunch of baking powder brands that are
kosher for Passover if you'd prefer to
not use baking powder you can absolutely
substitute it with seltzer
there are countless ways to make matzo
ball soup and no one way is the right
way this is just what I remember from my
own childhood I saw my grandparents
every weekend of my childhood and my
grandma was like a second mom to me I
had your average American Ashkenazi
Jewish upbringing my mom is Jewish and
she took my sister and me to Temple when
we were growing up I had a Bar Mitzvah
and these days I can phonetically read
Hebrew but I truly don't know what most
of the words mean anymore I like growing
up in a Jewish household a lot it was a
little odd being the only practicing
Jewish kid in my high school class but
as time has passed I've gained more of
an appreciation for Judaism I really
love being Jewish it's given me a really
beautiful community over the years
freezing matzo balls doesn't affect
their taste or texture at all especially
if you're prepping a large number of
matzo balls
you can absolutely freeze them ahead of
time my grandparents chose to freeze
them before putting them into the soup
at the end to make sure they would
retain their dumpling shape in a warm
liquid they didn't want to risk the
matzo balls disintegrating into a matzah
stew when I was a kid for Passover we
would go over to my grandparents house
and they would host a big seder with
family and friends nowadays one of my
friends in Los Angeles
usually hosts the Seder at their house
and out of the kindness of their heart
they invited me over to it I loved a lot
of the Jewish holidays but Passover
might actually be my favorite one just
it's tied to so many wonderful family
memories my favorite part of it was
singing the four questions with my
sister traditionally it's only the
youngest person at the table who recites
the four questions but my sister and I
would share the duty because we like to
do it together
the Seder Plate and everything that goes
on it looks lovely there's a few foods
for Passover that maybe are harder to
capture on camera matzo ball soup might
be a little gray odd-looking but it's so
delicious
appearances can be deceiving but maybe
you'll look at this and you'll think
it's absolutely delicious whether or not
you're Jewish if you're going to a
Passover Seder I hope you have a
wonderful time and enjoy your matzo ball
soup oh yes
[Music]